bonsoir la centrale nucléaire du
tricastin dans le département de la
drôme a connu il y à plus d'un mois une
fissure sur une tuyauterie d'un système
de sécurité si les conditions des normes
de sécurité avaient été respectées la
production d'énergie devait s'arrêter
il n'en a rien été de plus on a attendu
selon une bonne vieille habitude dans ce
domaine plusieurs semaines avant de
révéler cet incident explication patrick
esther c'est sur la tranche numéro 4 de
la centrale du tricastin que les
techniciens d'edf ont procédé il y a
quatre semaines peut-être un peu
rapidement à une réparation sur un
minuscule tuyaux de 12 mm de diamètre
une affaire a priori banale si ce
n'était que ce tuyau fait partie du
système de sécurité chargés dix noms des
deux bords le coeur du réacteur
ce produit empêche le réacteur de
s'emballer
si sa température augmente brusquement
par exemple à la suite d'une fuite de
vapeur dans le circuit qui alimente la
turbine cette réparation a été effectué
par les agents edf sans que les
autorités de sûreté soi-même seulement
consulté la procédure administrative n'a
donc pas été respectées or toute la
sécurité du système nucléaire française
repose sur le respect absolu des
procédures nous avons l'habitude dans
nos exploitations de faire les choses
d'une façon assez formaliser et en
l'occurrence
il aurait peut-être été souhaitable que
on procède en considérant qu'il
s'agissait fait effectivement dans
l'incident significatif mais je dois
dire que les résultats auraient été
n'aurait pas été différent le type de
réparation aurait été celui qui a été
pratiquée à la centrale donc je me
répète c'est bien un problème de
procédure d'appréciation de procédure
qui que l'on peut discuter en fait mais
qui ne pose pas problème
à aucun moment on a frisé l'accident
dans le pire des cas le tuyau en cause
aurait déversé 20 tonnes d'eau
radioactive dans le bâtiment voisin pour
décontaminer cette installation la
centrale aurait dû alors être arrêtée
très longtemps bénéfices obtenus grâce à
la réparation ultra rapides effectués
sans arrêter le réacteur néant
la direction d'edf en apprenant la chose
a décidé d'arrêter la centrale pour la
réparer une seconde fois
selon les normes